das ist so dass mit dem astra zeneca ist
dass herr der ringe gestartet wurde
das bedeutet dass während noch klinische
prüfungen laufen und die entwicklung
nicht komplett abgeschlossen ist wir
bereits datenpakete zugesandt bekommen
bei der europäischen arzneimittelagentur
diese daten sichten teil bewerten können
rückfragen darzustellen und diese
rückfragen vom antragsteller dann auch
beantwortet werden können
dieser prozess läuft bis zum stand heute
morgen war der vollständige antrag noch
nicht eingereicht worden und nach
einrechnung des vollständigen antrag
kann dann sehr schnell eine bewertung
vorgenommen werden so dass man dann zu
einer endgültigen stellungnahme kommt
das wird gerade heute auch in einer
konferenz der immer geschäftsstelle
geklärt und wir versuchen hier so
schnell wie möglich da auch
voranzukommen und da nichts ist im
moment daran dass der vollständige
antrag dann nachteil bewertung
eingereicht werden muss dann können wir
das land mit der zulassung heute machen